so as you'll see we have a wonderfully
full program for the day and a great
deal to get through so my other job
apart from being your guide is to be
your timekeeper wish me luck
now to get things started I'm delighted
to introduce Simon Blackburn the
philosopher who is a federal initi
College Cambridge to tell us the story
of truth
[Applause]
thank you
mm-hmm it's great pleasure to be here
today and I'd like to thank all my hosts
the Nobel Committee for inviting me it's
an even greater privilege to kick off
the proceedings on such a a difficult
topic for most of my 50 plus years in
academic life our theories of truth for
being the preserve the private preserve
of philosophers and logicians but now
that worries about our post truth
environment attract such attention the
interest has spread and that is why we
are here today well the first thing I
want to say is that worries about truth
can take very different forms
we might be worried firstly about the
reliability of our sources whether their
sources in observation or sources in the
testimony of other people we might be
worried about their competence their
objectivity their trustworthiness this
is not a recent problem but a permanent
complaint throughout human history lies
propaganda wishful thinking superstition
conspiracy theories bias and the
outright delusions have always been with
us in some respects it may be better now
when the world is so thoroughly
monitored and observed and researched
there's another respect of course it may
be worst there's more noise in the
system now that any one mischievous
enough to want to do so can broadcast
whatever they'd like others to believe
and there may be more sinister
distortions as well when we reflect how
power and money influence so much of
what we hear and read and we might
rightly worry that what power and money
want us to hear and read is what we end
up hearing and reading this can happen
in science too for example in his book
about the distortions of medical science
the writer and dr. Ben Goldacre reported
how their clinical trials giving
companies sponsoring the trials give
them what they're funded by companies
who sponsor the trials give them what
they want in one example of 56 trials
comparing painkillers in every case the
sponsoring manufacturers product came
on top implying the logical
impossibility that each of these drugs
was better than all the others talking
about human credulity in the belief in
miracles the great philosopher David
Hume said that the wise lend a very
academic faith to any report that
flatters the patters of the reporter and
he was surely right a different worry
but related is that the vocabularies
that we use to describe things are
themselves distorting our thoughts about
them this was a particular concern of
classical philosophers indeed according
to Aristotle a philosopher who might
have taught Plato called Cratylus was so
concerned about this that he lapsed into
total silence and would only communicate
by wagging his finger the Greek
historian Thucydides made the same
complaint over 2,000 years ago talking
of the Peloponnesian War Thucydides says
words had to change their ordinary
meaning and to take that which was now
given them reckless audacity came to be
considered the courage of a loyal
supporter prudent hesitation became
specious cowardice moderation was held
to be a cloak for unmanned leanness
ability to see all sides of a question
was incapacity to act on any of them
frantic violence became the attribute of
manliness cautious plotting a
justifiable means of self-defense
defense he might have been talking about
the political situation in Britain the
present was offer another salient modern
example consider the vocabulary is used
in the psychiatric dictionary the
Diagnostic and Statistical Manual of
Mental Disorders of the American
Psychiatric Association DSM 1 was
published in 1952 and contained a
hundred and thirty two pages DSM was her
5 was published in 2013 and contained
947 pages suggesting that we now have
only over seven times as many disorders
as a few years ago controversies over
this inflation included allegations of
secrecy accusations of conflicts of
interest
charges of medicalizing normality and
other claims of poor methodology so here
finding the right words is a difficult
task and making the observations that
were justified diagnosis is a difficult
task the world does not supply us with a
ready-made
directory perhaps classifying syndromes
that suggest a problem in somebody's
mind is like classifying the shapes of
waves or clouds and the Cratylus thought
it was always like that
what then about truth itself well the
first thing everybody thinks or says
about truth is that it is correspondence
with the facts and that's indeed a
perfectly sensible thing to say
it's a platitude so it may come as a
surprise to many of you that
philosophers and little logicians line
up to pour cold water on what they call
the correspondence theory of truth this
hostility is not directed at the
platitude but at the idea that it
provides a theory as opposed to a
vacuous synonym it would only provide a
theory critics say if we could think of
something like the correspondence of a
portrait to a sitter we could judge that
correspondence because we have but can
we have we can have both in front of us
and compare one to the other
but when all we have to go on our
established data points on our best
theories about some issue we cannot find
that separate vantage point we cannot
step outside our best theories and
compare them with the facts to see how
well they correspond we can try to
improve our observation certainly but
observation and observations provide the
stimulus to changing our portraits but
at any time we have only our portraits
but no independent access to the sitter
you might have thought that facts for
things like objects in space that you
can literally come across but they're
not they have no location you can't move
them about if you think especially of
hypothetical facts negative facts
general facts facts about possibilities
facts about necessities you will get
some sense of the difficulty many
philosophers therefore
agree with the American a logician
willard van orman quine
of harvard who said that facts are
fictions spurious sentence like slices
of reality projected from the true
sentences for the sake of correspondence
if the idea of correspondence gives us
no practical handle on truth perhaps we
need to turn through the procedures we
use in order to fix it of course we have
data points we have observations but
observations take interpretations all
those psychiatrists were observing
patients but what they interpreted was
very different from 1952 to 2013
observations expand our overall field of
belief and we absorb them in 12 views of
the world as best we can so our
practices of inquiry are ones of
substituting more comprehensive coherent
sets a belief for what we believe
previously this suggests that a drive
towards truth is just a drive towards
max and coherence and some philosophers
have thought that as well but there
might not a splendidly coherent set of
beliefs about the world be completely
off track if coherence is all we can
expect and yet coherence leaves an open
possibility of falsehood naira then
perhaps we ought to become altogether
skeptical about our capacities for truth
such has been the conclusion of some
post modernists but sober philosophers
of science as well have worried along
the same lines in 1906 the physicist
pierre duhem introduced the idea of the
under determination of theory by data
meaning that there are always different
ways of accommodating data into theory
and they're not therefore never just the
one unique coherent theory possible at
any given time so who is to say which is
right Einstein himself much influenced
by DM wrote that if two theories are
available both of which are compatible
with the given factual material then
there's no other criterion for
preferring the one to the other than the
intuitive view of the researcher others
have gone some way toward skepticism
recommending that we should not really
believe our theories but only accept
them in a wait-and-see spirit constantly
on the lookout
for difficulties and refutations we
should notice there that if certainly if
two theories are available and in
practice it's usually hard enough to
find one reasonable coherent and
comprehensive theory of things not to
have to choose between two and other
virtues are also available to play a
role in theory choice simplicity economy
familiarity fertility all play a role
and serve course does the utility of
theories very often the proof of the
pudding is in the eating well you may
think that's all very well as good
common sense methodology but have we
actually said what truth in itself is
doesn't pilots questions still hang in
the air
many contemporary philosophers perhaps
the majority think not the great German
pioneer of modern logic Gottlob Frager
suggested why consider any particular
thought or belief for example the belief
that dolphins are mammals if I say that
and you reply that's true you're not
adding a new fact about the belief but
you're simply expressing assent to it we
don't have to claims to consider firstly
that dolphins are mammals and secondly
that it's true that dolphins are mammals
there's no additional content to the
claim made using the idea of truth in
fact they couldn't be since if there
were it would launch a sauna into
infinite regress of different claims
whales are mammals it's true that whales
are mammals it's true that it's true
that whales are mammals and so on with
each claim making a remark about the
previous one frege's arguments suggest
what is now called a deflation astoria
malloced account of truth talking about
the truth of an issue is just talking
about the issue itself
well our philosophers then asked why we
have the notion if it disappears so
readily and there many things to say
about that deflation ism allows that for
example we think we ought to aim at
truth because for an arbitrary for P you
think you ought to aim to believe P only
if P if you think that scientists are
successful in building iPhones because
their electronic theories are true you
think they're successful because P 1 to
P n
for arbitrary electronic assertions p1
to PN belonging to their theories in
this way we can understand the aim of
truths and explanations given in terms
of truth without ourselves deploying the
notion without needing to find in the
ocean the answer to pilot so in pilot
asks what is truth the deflation Estonia
replies what are you interested in if
you're interested in whether a defendant
is guilty then the truth about the issue
consists in the defendant being guilty
or in him not being guilty and it's your
job to find out about that not to worry
about the philosophy it follows that we
can't live in a genuinely post truth
world as long as we continue to live an
act in the world at all for to act we
have to have beliefs to test beliefs to
inquire and to do as best we can to sift
out those to hold and there's not to
hold so they're going to be things we
call true and others which we think
false even president Trump understands
the difference although he may not care
about it as he should he deploys the
difference every night whenever he
accuses his enemies of supplying fake
news does this man mean that there's
nothing to worry about
not at all the real problems are already
in front of us their problems of
epistemology problems of trust problems
of trustworthiness and their problems of
finding words adequate to our needs but
these are always good things to worry
about but case by case problem by
problem they are often things we can
solve post modernists were wrong to mock
the Enlightenment hope for and belief in
progress thank you
[Applause]